[Music]
whenever we think of great teams
more often than not we think of their
superstars
the highlight spamming larger-than-life
maestros who become
the faces of their games uh his tens
he's got the frenzy
and he's got a kill man all up and moves
his face and he's getting a jumping one
as well on the thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it but usually
what makes a great team
truly great is a leader the voice of
reason
the calm during the storm and the
rallying cry to lift those around them
why am i so much better than you igls
are
organizers strategists and selfless
conductors
who put the team before their own stat
lines
cerebral assassins who typically work in
the shadows but
when called upon aren't afraid to step
into the light
and lead by example he's thinking about
jumping stories gets the info he just
has to hit this shot and he's done it
for heroic
the leader calling well above his ears
clearing corners
now of course every igl will have their
own philosophy
and approach to communicating with their
own teammates
but one thing all great leaders must
have to truly motivate those around them
is confidence the unquestioning belief
that their every call is the right one
and that no situation
is insurmountable it might not matter oh
magus he had the hell for it but now
he's been taken out and sip
just trying to buy time flank it around
blame it hunting him down
he turns forward immediate defuse he's
right there with a kid
oh my god i can't believe it's 16 and
12.
but when it comes to taking the reins
and inspiring confidence in others
perhaps no igl approaches leadership
quite like
jake poster howlett fnatic's charismatic
comedic captain an unorthodox entry
fragger turned shotcaller
who hasn't just spent the past year
molding his team into one of valrant's
very best
but has done so all while making himself
something
of a spectacle i will be your igl today
please
step in line for the services of the igl
i've got a few strats in mind first of
all we're starting off with the
brimstone
on bind this the voice are we getting
the voice really
is this trademarked are we allowed to
show this he's in
i don't know if vikings are gonna show
up and bring some uh thunder
and take down liquid um because uh
lightning is super effective against
water types
um but who knows i mean i don't know
what i'm saying
so how exactly did this spotlight loving
madman harness his natural energy as an
entertainer
and turn it into a competitive gaming
career what about his background
might explain his unusual behavior and
more importantly
how are boasters goofy antics helping to
fuel
fanatic success in valorant look at
where suggest is
he's tucked down close oh
what
okay guys dimitri's out for this video
so it falls on my shoulders to tell you
to like the video
subscribe to the channel and ring the
notification bell
i can't make you do it because i'm not
your igl
but if i was your igl we're russian bee
alright so before he clowned his way
into the grand finals of valoran's first
major land
and prior to becoming a viral sensation
in china
what was fnatic's late blooming animated
igl
up to well if you've seen what he's like
in front of a camera
it might not surprise you to hear that
growing up in england
boaster was actually a theater kid with
dreams of becoming a professional
performer
and even though these days he's mostly
occupied bossing it with brim daddy
he's never too busy to put on a show for
his
i look in the fans i melt your heart in
a two
i got the super soul closer
to the boogie like side step right left
to my feet
highlight the moon
creative interests aside boaster's been
gaming for
as long as he can remember he poured
hours into games like world of warcraft
but
eventually his natural hunger for
competition
led him to league of legends but like
seemingly every younger brother under
the sun
boaster discovered what he felt was his
true calling
in 2012 when he was introduced to cs go
my brother used to play a lot and um he
wouldn't let me play but in
my spare time i managed to get a couple
of hours every day and uh i just went
from then on really i was streaming got
noticed and then
voila i just want to i just love
competing i just want to beat people
by early 2015 boaster was trying to make
a name for himself by competing in
smaller rosters in the uk's minor cs
scene but he was struggling to find a
spot on any top roster
why because well name me a top
cs roster from the uk go ahead i'm
waiting
oh rude anyway boaster spent a good
chunk of 2017 competing with
excel esports but with most results not
going the team's way
he began streaming for them instead
despite his obvious drive and commitment
to the game
boaster's competitive cs career appeared
to be spinning its tires
but in december of that year he was
presented with an
opportunity that would change everything
hi i'm jake and i just won a trip to
mexico
welcome to the hard rock hotel ecs
finals get your boasties
boaster managed to win a competition run
by face it
that allowed him to attend the ecs
finals in cancun mexico
where he'd be co-hosting the event
alongside machine
and nothing and i think it's fair to say
that he enjoyed his time there
[Applause]
whether he was interviewing some of the
best cs players and casters in the world
boaster stole the show whenever he found
himself
in front of the camera so much so that
facet offered him the chance to produce
more video content for them going
forward after returning home
bowser continued his cs grind and even
managed to win a small event alongside
smooya
but before long he was back in front of
the camera at the ecs season 5 finals
and then at the london major later that
year but as
boaster was sitting there watching some
of the greatest counter-strike teams in
the world
battling it out on the game's biggest
stage he was inspired
to make a promise to himself i'm gonna
be praying one day guys i'm gonna be pro
i'm gonna sit in a booth i'm gonna sit
on the stage
and i'm gonna play in front of the big
audience what's up [ __ ] the problem was
that
even though boaster was more motivated
now than ever
to make it as a pro player he still
needed to find a consistent paycheck
and so he took his experience creating
content for faceit and
rejoined excel not as a competitor or
streamer
but this time as a vlogger for their
league of legends team
i thought this vlogging job was a great
opportunity and i just
didn't want to say no right now i feel
like my time can be spent
grinding cs uh learning how to create
better vlogs
learning how to make videos learning uh
team dynamics like because i'm behind
their team so it's nice to see
there's quite a cool perspective seeing
how in other games
teams kind of practice slightly
different to cs go actually so
that's quite cool but after spending the
better part of a year
sharpening his skills as a content
creator for the org
boaster's attention shifted in april of
2020
with the arrival of valorent
even in its beta boasters saw the
potential invalorant
and with the game's promise of an
eventual esports scene
he decided to leave his role with excel
and fully commit to it
which he recently told upcomer i've got
10
000 pounds to my name i'm gonna just
like
i've got about eight months to a year of
grinding before that money runs out
like on rent and whatnot i'm gonna try
and go pro and
yeah and that's kind of what happened
poster became consumed by valorent
sharpening his own skills while putting
together guides for new players
and while the game was already proving
to be a launching pad for content
creators
boaster was determined to go pro but to
do that
he needed a team so in august 2020 he
joined sage alt my nan
football club aka summon fc
a team that following his arrival was
made up of two cs players
and three former fortnite players with
most of the roster being young
and relatively inexperienced boaster
found himself
as the old man on the roster despite
only being
26 and so for the first time in his
career
he decided to take up the reigns as the
team's igl
an endeavor he talked about with
platchat valorant
yeah i knew i knew that the boys would
have to learn quite a bit
um like they they all could shoot and
as long as you get people that can kill
that means they have that kind of like
natural
ability to feel out the game if you got
that
then um teaching the other stuff is
tedious but it is possible now during
the earliest stages of valoran's
competitive scene
most people's attention was on big
organizations like
g2 and team liquid teams who had
recruited established and adored cs
talent
looking for a fresh start but once riot
announced valorent's first big event
first strike summons saw it as a chance
to announce themselves to the scene
and after a grueling qualification
process
they punched their ticket to the eu
regional finals as one of
only eight teams once there boaster and
the boys quickly proved that
they shouldn't be slept on summon fc the
barrel shows that's one
doma goes back in he's gonna guess the
second one excellent play from doma
with 14 seconds spike on the shoulder
he does mo is doing everything for his
side right now
and time is of the essence machine is
desperate for this but time
four seconds left this is easy they just
need to live a machine has no options
available
gg well played chances are pretty fair
in this one and machine's position is
gonna be rough oh my god mo somehow wins
that fight
and he's still a good head shot he's
just turreting around on his own
in the end summon may have fallen short
in the grand finals but
after outperforming some of the region's
most hyped teams
they'd earned the attention of the
community and
more importantly fnatic who signed them
not long after the event
now of course with the prestige of
playing for an esports org like fnatic
comes the pressure of actually having to
perform
and after a few less than stellar
performances and some qualifiers for
valorent's first ever
international lan the team brought in
magnum and durka
in a bid to add extra firepower to the
lineup
and in challengers 2 their move paid off
this but he's only got one oh well
that's all he needs oh my god but durka
he's lost his opponent where did he go
well there he is durka who eventually
takes him down
usually in their favor it is now only
pistols and even magnum
wiping them out with the double kill
that's just beautiful
once again fnatic fell short in the
grand finals
but despite losing to liquid they
qualified for iceland as europe's
second seed after six years of grinding
to make a name for himself as an esports
pro
boaster had finally made it not only was
he part of a tier one org as a player
but as a leader and he was going to get
the chance to lead his team onto valor's
biggest stage
yet fnatic started the event off strong
dumbsterring crew but as impressive as
their performance was on the server
boaster's behavior turned some heads
and that ends in the fashion that i
would have expected early on from fnatic
right again you give them an inch they
take a mile and those are the sorts of
rounds
but they just look so damn good poster
like i said ice box was one that
potentially yes you could consider it
an anomaly in this map pool across these
two teams is this is the weirdest
winning celebration i've seen no
surprise
boasters at the center of it we're
looking on forum we're looking
like first first ever stage uh first
ever performance on stage for some of
these lads and they were hitting
gnarly headshots crisps crisp locks and
uh
yeah i mean that is why because we we're
having fun
and that's where we're gonna win now
unfortunately for fnatic their momentum
came to a screeching halt when they ran
into sentinels on day two
but even with their backs against the
wall in the dreaded lower bracket
boaster wasn't going to let one loss get
to them
are you expecting a doom and gloom scene
i'll give you one
do you enjoy filming me and my sadness
and after resetting their composure
fnatic started to claw their way through
the gauntlet that lay before them
and they did it with style take until
then magnum being a loss is a bit of an
issue
building but mystic bails him out with a
stunner
spins around on a dime gets three and
now paddy pan has to dig deep on this
now two left already spread it out one
earlier
yeah so he knows where the last two
players are he could still do work on
this one
but how does he stop this he can't
darker
plucks him out and says no that's four
on the board for fnatic
actually at this point i mean finding
mystic but right here i mean there's
there's nothing to cover off nobody's
swept through this side of pipes
nobody's even holding the side of maize
the boats are able to
line the first two up and has a free
peak onto the third as well
great work there but they are coming
back in mystic no way
and it's just paddy pants no way did
they just
do that yeah the spike's planted but the
damage is being done poster
swings right back in doubles on it
that's sick work from boaster
yeah isn't it and it's just that slight
adjustment here where they find again
save round for v1 and i guess a little
bit deeper in terms of early round
aggression
magnum's down boaster tries to hit that
flank
just like a knife in the back he finds
effie's in jammies dirk durko ducker
hold on
he's gonna have one he's got two it
could not happen oh
[Music]
sending version one home living through
the lower bracket
this is exceptional from fnatic and i
don't know what celebration is going to
be now but i think you can see what this
means to them
they make it one step further
is this north america going home on the
airplane right now
it does look like it is now of course a
major part of fnatic's success
was their chemistry and their game play
but there's no
question that boaster's bizarre antics
and leadership style
wasn't just for the cameras it was
serving a greater purpose
there is something to be said about
having someone like boaster to lighten
the mood for the team these are
young players and we'll say it time and
time again we'll have to constantly go
over because it is a big point
at this point you do need someone who's
gonna be that emotional lift he's
definitely a hype man
he's definitely a good rock
to our team like as in like if it wasn't
for his energy and
hype i don't think we would be here i
don't know where poster gets his energy
from i might need to like
start eating all the food he eats or
something
you just gotta be crazy boys i'm just
i'm crazy
fnatic continued to ride their good
vibes
all the way through tough match-ups
against liquid
and new turn earning themselves a shot
at redemption against sentinels in the
grand finals
and if you think that the increased
stakes might give boaster some serious
stage fright
you clearly haven't been paying
attention they go through to be maine
now after that long delay sentinels
trying to
remove fanatic from positions all they
have is position right now
tens is there now able to help dapper as
that wall goes down
and this is beautiful just enough time
bought there by that cage
and now shazam swings in sentinels are
looking
fantastic and that's it sentinels
will win map one in overtime and it will
do just that taking down the defuser
zombs has to get these forward kills
to hold the stick oh my god he's gonna
drop dapper
and it doesn't look like there's time
here for zombs to win this one can't
find the spray it's
boaster all day here comes the stick
shazam trying to dance
it's optimistic wow he protects turka
and we're going
to another overtime here on map two
indeed
mystic not expected fury coming out and
dapper
will take down wow wow pick up
bind they pick up the map of fnatic
map two goes to central and that's a 2-0
start in this best of five
the one was close they don't know oh my
god he gets less the team flash
the team flash magnums in the smoky
attempt oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels
they're gonna get the defuse they've
done it sentinels
are the masters to reikobic champions
and they do it flawlessly they didn't
drop a single map
stunned fanatic in the end
boaster and fnatic came up short again
against sentinels
but they emerged as heroes for their
region
overall i think in in terms of our
mentality and stuff we stayed in the
game like we never gave up so
we can look back at this uh on this loss
and actually
like be proud you know be proud of
yourself boys because it's our first lan
you know and there's many more to come
and we'll get our revenge
even though there had been no crowd
present at masters
it didn't change the fact that boaster
had kept the promise
he'd made to himself back in 2018 and to
him
that felt like a victory i'm and
like i never thought i would be pro
like when i stopped playing
counter-strike so to be on the stage now
and be pro
i want to really just like enjoy the
moment of when i imagined it when i was
like 18 trying to be pro you know i
i i i could always visualize myself up
on the stage and just being like
if i can get on a stage i can like be an
idiot and perform and stuff and
that's kind of like how i went into it
and this is my opportunity so
i'm just gonna enjoy the moment live
with no regrets of this event and
just be positive and make sure that my
teammates this is some of their first
ever lan events you know
and i just want to make sure that when
looking back they it's a like positive
memory for them and
that's kind of how i how i feel while
boaster's breakout performance may not
have yielded a trophy for his
team there's no denying that it won him
the hearts of valorent fans
and since the event they now flock to
his daily stream by the
thousands to see him clapping kids one
on b
side
[Music]
one enemy remaining [ __ ] 30 seconds
left
putting on trademark performances for
his international followers
[Music]
[Music]
there we go or you know just generally
acting like a maniac
fast here one two
one more there oh my goodness what is
going on with me am i on steroids of
this game
look at me i'm like you want to come to
my site what's this
[Music]
knife smoke smoke smoke smoke punch
punch punch jab
in the end the sad truth is that esports
careers typically
have an expiry date so seeing someone
like boaster enjoying every moment of
the experience
regardless of the results is simply
refreshing
and honestly after working his ass off
for years to get himself into the
spotlight
he's more than deserving of using it
however he pleases
yeah anyone we are anyone that stuck
with me in this battle
we're going to rise to the current we're
going to rise to the moment
oh my goodness definition take down
susan
[Music]
so in august 2020 he joined sage alt my
nan football
club aka s-u-m-n-f-c a team that
sage all my man
[Laughter]
can sage can sage rez people who died of
natural causes
is that possible is sage like a
freelancer who just rezzes old rich
people for money
is that is that what i would never think
to be like res my grandpa gaming
that i just that's wild dude that's like
such a good name holy [ __ ]